Three replicas, new image, zero downtime, that's a deployment.
A deployment manages a set of paths.
You describe the desired state.
The controller continuously reconciles actual to desired.
Under the hood, it wraps a replica set.
You don't touch replica sets directly.
Change the image tag, and a new replica set spins up.
The old one scales down gradually, never all at once.
The old replica set is kept, that's your rollback target.
Four operations you need to know.
Scale replicas up or down instantly.
Roll back to a previous revision with Cubectl Rollout Undo.
Pause a rollout to batch multiple changes, then resume.
Check progress with Cubectl Rollout status.
A how you run stateless apps in production.
Set the replica count, set the image, let Kubernetes handle the rest.
Run the docs, Kubernetes deployments.